[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce tout
premier set 8 sport de l'année 2020 à
ces parties a pour le sommaire football
versailles affronter ce week-end
granville en 32e de finale de la coupe
de france s'est déversée ils n'ont pas
réussi à se qualifier pour le tour
suivant
ils ont été éliminés retour sur ce match
dans ce magazine agenda coup de
projecteur sur les plus grands
événements sportifs qui vont rythmer les
yvelines cette année il y aura notamment
du cycliste avec le tour de france ou
encore le paris nice plus de détails à
suivre
course à pied zoom dans cette émission
sur la diagonale des yvelines le rendez
vous aura lieu le 28 mars prochain près
de 600 coureurs devraient s'inscrire
pour participer notamment aux 85 et 46
km nous recevrons les organisateurs
l'actualité sportive c'est maintenant
sur tv 78
[Musique]
on commence tout de suite par du
football il n'y a plus de club yvelinois
en coupe de france l'épopée de versets
s'est finalement terminé en 32e de
finale les versets ils se sont inclinés
2 buts à 1 face à granville dans leur
stade mob aurons des images de grégory
canal est un montage de jules grenat
ville un stade bien garni pour une
affiche historique 2000 supporteurs ont
fait le déplacement pour voir ce 32e de
finale de coupe de france entre
versailles et granville les versets qui
évolue en nationale 3 n'avait plus
atteint ce stade de la compétition
depuis 2011
aujourd'hui qui va marquer malgré leurs
divisions d'écart les versets qui marque
en premier sur penalty mais se font
rejoindre quelques minutes plus tard le
score à la mi temps un partout je pense
que techniquement les deux équipes se
valent mais ça va jouer à très serré
granville marquera un second but en
seconde période malgré quelques actions
en fin de match et les encouragements de
leurs supporters
versailles ne reviendra pas et se fait
sortir de la coupe de france sur le
score de 2 1 ils ont entre un petit peu
plus d'expérience que nous la succion se
meut sur ce genre de match qui sont
quand même important donc j'ai tiré un
petit plus d'expérience après je pense
pas qu'on avait quelque chose à leur
envier qu'il soit techniquement ou
physiquement
une ou deux erreurs sans ciment qui nous
ont coûté des buts on a été punis
froidement mais voilà c'est la vérité du
32e de finale de coupe de france de ce
niveau là et là dessus il faut il faut
apprendre
du côté des supporters les sentiments
sont partagés on est quand même content
de la prestation des joueurs mais on
aurait pu gagner et faire beaucoup mieux
mais c'est pas grave on a vécu quand
même un bon match quand on regarde le
contenu ça laisse ça laisse des regrets
pourquoi c'est dommage voilà maintenant
il ya des fêtes je veux continuer je
pense qu'ils vont gagner le championnat
de n3 les versets sont à l'heure
actuelle premiers du championnat de
nationale 3 avec un point d'avancé sur
leur dauphin ivry pour se remettre de
cette défaite en coupe il faudra
l'emporter ce samedi 11 janvier à
domicile contre l'équipe 2 du paris
saint germain
on continue à parler à de football dans
le championnat de première division de
district ont joué en match en retard
bailly noisy s'est facilement imposée à
domicile sur le score de 3 buts à 0 face
au peg ce dimanche un résultat qui leur
permet de remonter à la sixième place du
classement avec 13 points l'équipe
compte encore deux matches en retard à
jouer
il y avait également du handball ce
week-end en championnat de nationale 2
féminine montigny retenue s'est imposé
contre saint marcel vernon lors de la 9e
journée l'elysée montrent l ont emporté
25 à 14 au classement cette victoire
permet aux saint-quentinoise de revenir
à hauteur du leader tall carantec avec
23 points la deuxième partie de saison
s'annonce passionnante
un mot de boxe à présent c'était l'un
des combats français de cette fin
d'année au palais des sports de
marseille le very roi ahmed el moussaoui
s'est imposé aux points par décision
unanime face aux russes vague inac comme
radian ce combat international compter
dans la catégorie des poids welters
moins de 69,8 kg ahmed el moussaoui
affiche désormais un bilan de 32
victoires 1 nul et 3 défaites il
voudrait maintenant au boxer pour un
championnat du monde en 2020 jeux
olympiques 2024 le label à terre de jeu
a été délivré deux nouvelles communes
des yvelines après avoir dévoilé dans un
premier temps 14 collectivités
yvelinoise le comité a rajouté dans sa
liste et la communauté d'agglomération
de rambouillet et que les sous-bois la
ville de rambouillet trappe
mantes-la-jolie versailles et buc
au total ce sont 21 une collectivité
yvelinoise qui décroche ce label
il permettra notamment commune de
participer aux jeux olympiques en
faisant des animations ou en accueillant
des sportifs ou
he has épreuve il y aura peut-être des
athlètes de ces deux clubs qui
participeront à ces jeux olympiques de
2024 nous recevons maintenant sur ce
plateau
l'entente athlétique de saint quentin en
yvelines avec philippe lefebvre et ses
délicats bourrin deux entraîneurs dans
la structure nous recevons également à
basile art et golly entraîneur à l'union
athlétique de versailles vous êtes venu
sur ce plateau pour nous parler de vos
clubs et du paysage de l'athlétisme dans
les yvelines mon soir alors tout d'abord
revenir sur cette année 2019
est-ce que ça a été une bonne année 2010
9 j'y vais pour le à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines 2019 une bonne
année à l'image de ce qu'est le club
c'est à dire avec des résultats de haut
niveau au niveau des cheveux de france
élite une athlète entraînée par cédric a
terminé 4e du 800 m et des résultats
chez les jeunes puisque nous sommes
depuis le début et nous tenons à le
rester un club formateur avec des titres
de champion de france sur des équipes de
minimes notamment voilà donc pour nous
une bonne année au niveau sportif une
bonne année aussi au niveau de la vie
associative puisqu'on a renouvelé nos
structures avec de nouveaux dirigeants
plein enthousiasme donc une bonne année
2010 9 cdec boire vous êtes d'accord
il s'est fait l'année 2019 pour le
double perspective
à l'avenir avec de bons jeunes qui sont
en train de monter donc toujours pour
l'instant c'est positif on du côté de
versailles
basile a rigolé bas du côté de lui avait
une année exceptionnelle et même
historique le fruit d'un travail de
plusieurs années qui voilà qui est qui
aboutit pourquoi exceptionnelle et
historique parce que on a atteint un
nombre de licenciés record au club on a
des 850 licenciés c'était sa 800 850
adhérents l'an dernier donc c'est la
première fois que le club passe hélas ce
cap des 800 adhérents donc et le chiffre
et accès exceptionnel parce qu'en disant
versailles est passé de 250 à 850
licenciés
voilà c'est ça exactement ça dont 50% en
moins de 15 ans exactement ça s'est
multipliée par 3 donc on a fait un gros
travail sur back sur la formation nous
aussi en accompagnant fidélisant les
jeunes en les détectant des partenariats
avec avec le monde scolaire
ça a permis vraiment d'étoffer notre
pôle jeunes et ensuite en s'ouvrant à
d'autres pratique de l'athlétisme en
ouvrant des sections je pense notamment
à section treille section marche
nordique cas permis vraiment d'étoffer
nos effectifs
et puis d'élever forcément le niveau
s'élève au niveau sportif s'est élevé
donc ça a tiré sa attirer des athlètes
désireux de nous rejoindre pour pour
évoluer progresser le club était
pourtant ancien il a été créé en 1977
est vraiment que depuis dix ans que le
club expose explose
disons que le club a connu dans une
autre période il ya une quinzaine
vingtaine d'années le haut niveau sous
une autre forme de politique
nous ensuite voilà pour des raisons
politiques financières il est redescendu
basse au niveau sportif des échelons un
échelon départemental je pense au niveau
des interclubs
il a fallu voilà reconstruire m m
différentes actions en place pour pour
créer voilà un nouveau cycle et
aujourd'hui on en récolte on en récolte
les fruits que ce soit en terme
d'attractivité mais aussi en terme de
résultats sportifs
du côté de saint quentin en yvelines
vous avez à peu près 900 licenciés un
petit peu plus est ce que vous vous
sentez cet engouement pour l'athlétisme
est ce qu'il ya un engouement pour
l'athlétisme tout simplement plus plus
de jeunes peut-être envie de scolaires
ont envie de s'engager peut-être dans la
bêtise vous avez lu l'engouement par la
clé pour l'athlétisme il ait pas de fait
un
on est un sport qui est un sport
difficile c'est un sport de patience
d'un sport d'investissement vous savez
aussi bien que moi que les jeunes
actuellement c'est la réussite immédiate
donc pour qu'un club d'athlétisme
réussisse il faut qu'ils aient un projet
ce que basile a décrit la sur son projet
qui a permis de relancer le club
c'est le projet qu'a lieu à saint
quentin en yvelines où on a mis en place
dès le départ c'est à dire une grosse
assise sur le milieu scolaire
cédric moi et d'autres entraîneurs et
qui sont passés au club qui sont encore
sont des enseignants de ps voilà là on
un vivier à partir de ce vivier il faut
travailler faut mettre en place des
structures dans le club pour les garder
et nous effectivement comme vous le
disiez on est plus de 900 on a passé un
petit peu la barre des 1000 l'année
dernière actuellement on et 975 on va
finir à plus de 1000 licenciés encore
cette année donc c'est un engouement
quand on voit ça parce que mille
licenciés dans un club c'est rare il y
en a pas beaucoup mais ça demande
beaucoup beaucoup d'investissements
parce que c'est pas un sport vers lequel
vont se diriger d'emblée les enfants il
faut le rendre ludique c'est un sport
encore une fois un sport d'efforts
l'athlétisme
donc bien sûr on a un tas d'astuces pour
le rendre intéressant chez les petits
mais c'est pas gagné à l'avancé ça que
je veux vous dire
donc oui il ya actuellement
et moi je suis ravi que lui à versailles
se développe parce que pendant longtemps
le à saint quentin en yvelines a été un
petit peu seul dans les yvelines nous
depuis la création du club on est
meilleur club des yvelines on est on est
le seul club des yvelines a évolué en
nationale 1 au niveau des interclubs
donc l'arrivée de l'ue à versailles elle
nous enthousiasme beaucoup surtout avec
cette nouvelle politique qui a décrit
basile nous on a connu lui à versailles
de ses débuts où effectivement c'était
pas du tout la même approche de
l'athlétisme
maintenant qu'on
qu'on est sur un travail on va dire
assez similaire base il l'a dit il
s'appuie beaucoup sur la structure
scolaire
il s'appuie beaucoup sur les jeunes il
fait dit lise ces jeunes il a un tas
d'actions qui l'amène à l'est à les
garder au club cédric vous en parlera
mieux que moi parce qu'en ce moment il
ya une dynamique au club sur le
demi-fond grâce à cédric qui remarque
justement cédric comment fait on les
garde ses pépites ces jeunes au club
alors on essaie de garder lorsque je
jouais rebondir un petit peu ce que des
défis c'est vrai qu'on parle beaucoup de
formation des athlètes mais la
difficulté est l'importance ou si c'est
la formation des encadrants
tous nos entraîneurs sont
essentiellement des jeunes des jeunes
athlètes conforme pour devenir
entraîneur animateurs et c'est vrai
qu'on y arrive de mieux en mieux et la
réussite de nos athlètes passent aussi
par la réussite de la formation de ses
entraîneurs après ce qu'il faut c'est
comme comme le fait basile aussi à
versailles est ce que nous on s'efforce
de faire c'est la dynamique du groupe
passionnément où on a un groupe qui
fonctionne pas du moment où les jeunes
se dynamiser ce motif est sûr contents
de se retrouver voit qu'il ya des
résultats bat les résultats et les
entraînements tout se fait un petit peu
de fil en aiguille et ça ça coule de
source on va dire donc c'est une vraie
dynamique
une dernière question quelles sont les
perspectives pour pour 2020 pour vos
clubs respectifs
on va commencer peut être par versailles
poursuivre poursuivre sur notre sur
notre lancée
c'est vrai que maintenant on a des
jeunes qui sont ambitieux qui veulent
faire de la performance donc nous ça
nous oblige entraîneur à élever
également nos compétences pour pouvoir
les accompagner au mieux possible dans
leur projet quel qu'il soit et quelle
que soit la durée dans laquelle ils
veulent s'inscrire et puis continuer à
offrir une offre qui s'adresse à tous
nos adhérents parce que faire que certes
y en a qui sont attirés par de la
performance d'autre part la compétition
d'autre part loisirs donc c'est vraiment
poursuivre nos actions et l'offrir à
proposer une offre qui correspond à la
demande et pour vos à saint quentin en
yvelines alors rapidement rapidement au
plan strictement sportif nos ambitions
restent des résultats au niveau donc je
voulais dit tout à l'heure on a une
athlète entraînée par cédric qui a
terminé 4e l'an passé sur 800 m je parle
des choix de france élite 1 donc elle
doit encore progresser on espère pour
elle un podium ça fait deux ans de suite
que on a des équipes championnes de
france de relais 4 x 100 quatre fois
deux comme lui à versailles avec ces
jeunes sur quatre fois mille en espère
réussir la passe de trois et garder ce
titre de champion de france
et puis dans nos équipes de jeunes et
bien on va en amener encore
quelques-unes sur les podiums nationaux
bien sûr mais c'est encore une fois ça
fait partie de notre adn
depuis la création de la saint quentin
gelé noter pour pas faire d'erreurs mais
on a dû 4 on a formé quatre
internationaux seniors voiliers et on a
formé très internationaux jeunes
donc on espère continuer dans cette
dynamique merci à tous les trois le
passé sur ce plateau vous souhaite
d'avoir deux futures pépites l'année
prochaine enfin cette année en 2020 et
pourquoi pas en 2024 au jo
on continue à part du un cyclisme
aujourd'hui je vous propose un coup de
projecteur sur jean michel richefort
affilié au club de vélizy 78 il a été
établi de nombreux records comme un
record de 24 heures sur son vélo au
vélotour national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en 2016 lors
du téléthon est aujourd'hui la
fédération française de cyclisme dans le
rôle de vice-président nous lui avons
posé trois questions
[Musique]
j'ai commencé le vélo par passion
j'avais 14 ans mais j'allais voir mon
cousin qui courait tous les dimanches en
limousin et puis ça m'a donné envie de
faire du vélo et bien sûr j'allais aussi
à l'école à vélo j'ai trouvé ça
formidable les copains l'ambiance
l'ambiance de la compétition puis j'ai
commencé en minimes cadets et je me suis
jamais arrêté
[Musique]
j'ai beaucoup de souvenirs mes souvenirs
qui m'a marqué particulièrement en vélo
c'est d'avoir participé au paris pékin à
vélo en 2008
donc paris fait qu'un don qu'il partait
le 16 mars du trocadéro et qui arrivé le
3 août au pied de la muraille de chine
mais là c'était un événement assez
exceptionnel et qui m'a permis également
de participer de voir les jeux
olympiques de pékin
donc
traversé à vélo plusieurs pays être
accueillis d'une façon très très simple
côtoyé différents différents peuples
et puis différents cycliste ça a été un
grand événement
les objectifs à vélo c'est de se
maintenir en forme
- maintenant je fais du vélo pour le
plaisir et pour la santé et lorsqu'on
fait du vélo et bien
on est heureux on fait du vélo pour sa
santé et je souhaite en faire très
longtemps on passe maintenant notre page
agenda
[Musique]
pour commencer cette page agenda je vous
propose de découvrir les grands
événements sportifs qui devraient
rythmer l'année 2020 à dans les yvelines
au programme du cyclisme de la course à
pied ou encore du volley ball
regardez 2020 sera placée sous le signe
du sport dans les yvelines c'est
désormais une habitude la course
paris-nice 2020 s'élancera pour la
onzième année consécutive depuis les
yvelines
d'après nos informations les coureurs
partiront le dimanche 8 mars prochain
depuis plaisir pour traverser une partie
du département
le lendemain l'état partira depuis
chevreuse pour rejoindre le loiret
paris-nice et la course au soleil
c'est la première grande course
internationale de la saison avec tirreno
adriatico et bien sûr la belle et les
meilleurs mondiaux seront au rendez vous
et c'est important d'avoir les plus
grandes et les plus grands coureurs
mondiaux au départ bien sur paris nice
c'est une très très grande course
internationale
le paris nice ne sera pas la seule
course cycliste organisée dans les
yvelines le tour de france passera
également par le département le 19
juillet prochain à mantes la jolie
le peloton s'élancera pour une dernière
étape de 122 kilomètres en direction des
champs elysées
c'est une formidable fête populaire
pendant trois semaines et une dernière
étape qui va traverser une grande partie
des yvelines à partir de mende
là c'est vraiment quelque chose il y
aura également des courses à pied dans
le département l'une des plus
importantes sur le paris versailles pour
cette 43e édition 25 mille coureurs
s'élanceront 1 27 septembre prochain
depuis la capitale pour un 16 2 km avant
cette date les yvelines vont accueillir
l'eco trail de paris le 14 mars prochain
l'une des plus longues courses de france
plusieurs centaines de participants vont
s'élancer depuis l'île de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines pour un trail
de 80 km qui les emmènera jusqu'à la
tour eiffel
parmi eux fabien parmentier de montigny
le bretonneux il participera sa 13ème
édition
les principales difficultés on va dire
c'est que c'est très roulant donc il
répétait commettre comme comme étant une
course très roulante c'est à dire sur
laquelle il ya peu de temps de repos on
court beaucoup n'y a pas forcément
beaucoup de dénivelés ya 1500 mètres de
dénivelé et donc à partir de là faut
sans cesse être dans la relance et avoir
une bonne
bonne gestion course à quelques mètres
de l'île de loisirs le vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines va
accueillir pour la première fois de son
histoire un match de volleyball
rencontre sera organisée le 28 mars
prochain il devrait opposer des équipes
de première division
saint quentin en yvelines devrait
également accueillir comme tous les ans
depuis 2002 l'open de france de golf le
rendez-vous retrouvera la saison
estivale du 2 au 5 juillet les
organisateurs pourrait néanmois
délocaliser l'événement dans le sud de
la france
enfin pour les plus courageux le mode
des paris sera organisé les 13 et 14
juin ben au programme 1 7 et 1 13 km et
surtout beaucoup de boue pour les
milliers de participants
on va maintenant parler d'un autre
événement qui sera organisé à cette
année la diagonale des yvelines pour
nous parler de ce rendez vous qui sera
organisée le 28 mars prochain nous
recevons les organisateurs alain
palausse bruno bachelard et bruno
poulenard bonsoir bonsoir est-ce que
vous êtes prêts à quelques semaines
quelques mois de l'événement ben là on
est si on a beau et on est bien avancé
puisque encore samedi dernier on était
sur le parcours pour pourvoir un petit
peu si tous passé on l'a fait
entièrement les 85km de breuil
boisrobert jusqu'à rochefort que dans
des conditions même s'il faisait beau
un petit peu compliqué parce que le
terrain n'était pas facile donc ça se
prépare
les inscriptions sont bien lancés
cette année on est la dernière c'est au
mois de juin cette année on l'a placé au
mois de mars parce qu'on trouve que
c'est un peu plus pertinent pour les
traders de la région c'est un peu mieux
situer au niveau du planning et donc bas
vont se préparer on a renforcé notre
équipe un petit peu cette année de
manière à accueillir les concurrents de
meilleures dispositions
bruno pourquoi le terme de diagonale la
diagonale tout simplement parce que
quand on regarde la carte des yvelines
mais on la traverse on la traverse un
peu pas dans l'axé nord-sud
donc on va partir on va dire un proche
de menthe et puis ensuite dirigés aux
confins des yvelines sur la petite ville
de rochefort qui est un village
magnifique proche du 91 voix là et on
traverse à part des sentiers par des
chemins de forêt on traverse différentes
vallées vallée de vaucouleurs un petit
peu la plaine de jeu russe et puis après
on est dans le massif forestier de de
rambouillet voilà tout simplement
bruno est ce que c'est une course
inédite on peut dire que c'est un peu
une course inédite parce que c'est un
petit peu atypique aussi c'est une
course qu'on peut appeler de ville à
ville course en ligne
mais c'est pas forcément des courses
commune général c'est plutôt des courses
qui partent d'une ville et qui est bas
qui ils font une boucle qui reviennent
au même point de départ
donc effectivement c'est une course un
petit peu atypique surtout pour le
département sur ces distances là il n'y
en a pas beaucoup
d'où nous le aussi la difficulté je
pense du parcours quels sont justement
les difficultés de ce parcours les
difficultés au delà de la distance ça va
être ça va être un petit peu le terrain
parce qu'au mois de mars on risque
d'avoir des conditions qui sont qui sont
encore assez humide et même si on aura
pas énormément de dénivelé je crois
qu'on parle peu près de 1000 2000 m de
dénivelé ça va être une succession de
petites bosses mais aussi de partie plus
roulante et sur 80 km ça risque de peser
lourd au final sur sur les cuisses
est-ce qu'il faut s'entraîner longuement
ou pas bon mais entraîné on s'entraînait
pour faire du fond et puis comme le
disait grenot un entraînement
particulier là j'invite tous les
concurrents a bien entraîné les
adducteurs les adducteurs tout
simplement parce qu'on passe dans des
terres qui sont un peu humide car des
yvelines et l'a automatiquement se
retrouver avec de l'équilibré trouvé un
on est sur deux pieds donc trouver sa
trace trouvé son équilibre que de la
glissade cesser le terrain est humide
obligatoirement il ya des glissades donc
l'entraînement il va être sûr de le
relief est un petit peu au départ sur
les surveille vos couleurs grand vallon
retrouver à la fin du côté rochois on a
un abou relief également sur rochefort
avec un peu de sable mais conseille les
adducteurs il faut les travailler ce
qu'il faut s'entraîner dès maintenant
pour ceux qui dès la rentrée ouais ouais
il faut pas hésiter faut mettre le
paquet ceux qui vont
qui vont partir sur le 185 il faut y
aller il faut y aller faut pas hésiter
c'est un travail de fond donc si on veut
arriver dans de bonnes conditions avant
les barrières horaires dans la nuit un
finir la course raisonnablement ce n'est
pas qu'une préparation musculaire aussi
préparation mentale c'est parce que sur
ces distances là du coup il ya vraiment
une grosse part du mental qui entrent en
jeu
parce que forcément 40 50 km on est tous
fatigués et à un moment donné c'est
mental après qui fait la différence et
qui permet d'avancer encore pour aller
pour aller jusqu'au bout justement un
apple est ce que tu peux faire cette
course alors tout le monde peut pas
faire de l'ultra s'appellera d'ultra
c'est pour ça qu'on a mis en place cette
année on a rajouté une petite distance à
12 km à 12 kilomètres au départ des
villages de rejouer en libye voilà qui
fera rochereuil rochefort alors pourquoi
parce que déjà parce qu'on veut on veut
ouvrir
la possibilité à tout le monde de
pouvoir faire cette course la diagonale
des yvelines donc il ya quatre courses
le 85 46 qui partent 85e' partir à
dreuilhe boisrobert le 46 qui partira de
saint léger en yvelines le vin qui
partirent à clairefontaine en yvelines
et donc le 12 qui qui parti fera la
boucle rochefort retourner me et
d'ailleurs on a choisi ça parce que
franchement la fin de parcours de
ressources ni n'est vraiment magnifique
on est sur des bois départementaux et
c'est vraiment un endroit qui est très
peu connue des yvelines et c'est
vraiment magnifique et bon là je le
vends un petit peu c'est normal mais
c'est vraiment un endroit magique et
très peu connu d'être ailleurs je pense
équipe qui avait conduit donc ce 12 km
permettra à tout le monde d'avoir au
moins participer à la diagonale des
yvelines
pour la seconde édition qu'est-ce qu'on
emporte qu'est-ce qu'on remporte alors
je crois savoir qu'il ya un repas
gourmand à la fin alors ce qu'on
remporte déjà c'est de l'avoir de
l'avoir fait d'avoir traversé quand même
en face et de l'apport personnel d'avoir
traversé quand même toutes les yvelines
dans sa diagonale c'est pas banal
et puis d'avoir visité que
et traversé plusieurs villages et à
l'arrivée une quinzaine de peser dans la
veine converser absolue à l'arrivée il y
aura une tartiflette à l'arrivée donc
l'année dernière c'était l'heure de
reprendre et on a trouvé que c'était un
peu d'époque la dernière c'était l'a pas
aidé à ces deux mois de juin ça
correspondait un peu plus à l'époque
et là on a décidé de faire une
tartiflette choucas sera bienvenue et on
mangera cet article est un petit point
auquel on s'attarde vraiment et qu'on y
est on y tient aussi à l'organisation
c'est que aux frais de remise des prix à
partir de 20 heures c'est à dire quand
le dernier coureur arrivé c'est quelque
chose auquel on tiers puisque ça se perd
un petit peu dans le monde de la course
et nous on sera on fera la remise des
prix et on veut que tout le monde tous
les coureurs ont participé soit là pour
actualiser les accueillir le dernier
arrivant si on est coureur et si on aime
la tartiflette
est ce que on peut encore s'inscrire
elles sont encore dépassées nous bien
sûr il reste encore des places
on est sur cette seconde édition il faut
qu'à moins que kas passe un petit peu
connaître
il reste on y reste des places et c'est
vrai que on espère que ça va monter j'y
croit les derniers on n'était pas loin
de 400 coureurs là si on atteint les 600
700 points on sera content ça sera
plutôt une réussite
et puis ben
je pense que le coureur qui aiment la
tartiflette et qui aiment les beaux
paysages s'inscrire à la dernière
le message est passé merci à tous les
trois le passé sur ce plateau je vous
rappelle les dates de la diagonale des
yvelines ce sera le 28 mars prochain
un rendez vous de ce début d'année à ne
pas manquer à manquer également
versailles promu cette année recevra
massif central ce dimanche 12 janvier à
15h dans son stade de porchefontaine une
rencontre importante pour les versets
qui sont dans le top 5 de ce championnat
après douze journées disputées qui
espère le rester en 2020 on écoute
pierre chevallier dirigeant au club il
nous présente les ambitions du club
cette année toujours le maintien
évidemment ça pour pour par prudence et
aussi par stratégie mais comme l'appétit
vient en mangeant lilly a peut-être
aussi maintenant une un nouvel objectif
qui vient d'arriver pour la saison 2009
1 en fédérale 3 c'est d'aller chercher
une place qualificative pour mémoire
c'est les quatre probables les quatre
premiers par dont il est le meilleur 5e
qui se qualifient pour les phases
finales de fédérale 3 du championnat de
france de fédérale 3 c'est la fin de
cette émission merci de l'avoir suivi
très belles années 2020 sur tv 78
[Musique]